il est candidat à l'élection
présidentielle nicolas dupont aignan
président de debout la france est
l'invitée de preuves par 3 bonsoir
bonsoir monsieur merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation donc de public sénat
avec l' agence france-presse et comme
chaque semaine trois grandes parties et
trois grandes questions auxquelles vous
allez devoir répondre d'abord françois
hollande at il raison de tenir bon sur
la loi travail pas question de céder dit
il aujourd'hui
on se marre des deux nouvelles
manifestations émaillées d'ailleurs de
violence comme à paris rennes et nantes
deuxième question alors que le risque de
dislocation de l'europe est évoqué face
aux crises multiples souhaitez-vous la
fin de l'europe vous le dirai à michael
ms de public sénat
enfin souhaitez-vous une alliance de
tous les souverainistes jusqu'aux
extrêmes de l'échiquier politique vous
répondrez à guillaume daudin de public
sénat de la fp grève reconductible
manifestation cortège émaillées de
violences donc je le disais le climat
social reste extrêmement tendue
mais françois hollande reste ferme sur
la loi travaillons l'écoutent doit elle
va passer pourquoi parce que il l a été
discutée elle a été concerté elle était
corrigée elle a été amendée
je ne céderai pas parce que il ya eu
trop de gouvernement je vais pas prendre
la liste trop doit y compris de ceux qui
font quelques critiques en ce moment il
ya eu trop de gouvernements qui ont cédé
et d'où l'état du pays que j'ai trouvé
en 2012 pour que moi même dans une
circonstance qui ne sont pas faciles je
puisse céder dès lors qu un conte social
a été trouvé un équilibre a été obtenu
que les syndicats réformistes sont
d'ailleurs ce texte et qu'il y a une
majorité de socialistes qui sont en
faveur de le voter
alors at elle raison de ne pas céder ce
après avoir déjà cédé d'ailleurs
puisqu'il évoque un texte corrigé
il dit qu'il ya une négociation n'y a
pas une négociation puisqu'elle 49,3 et
tous les français ont compris que
c'était un passage en force
mais si cette loi était utile à la
france aux entreprises aux salariés moi
je la voterai mais je voterai contre
cette loi qui est néfaste pour les
salariés et qui ne sera pas utile aux
entreprises
j'étais en haute-marne ya pas longtemps
mercredi et je rencontrais un
entrepreneur 20 salariés il faisait
cette fois c'est une catastrophe
elle va pas aider les pme elle va leur
compliquer la vie et en plus elle ne
récompense pas le travail pourquoi
suis contre cette loi c'est qu'elle ne
récompense pas les travailleurs les
heures supplémentaires c'est à dire un
salarié qui fait un effort
cette loi va baisser la rémunération des
heures supplémentaires d'accord dans
l'entreprise ah oui tout passe par des
accords d'entreprise des référendums
sous l'égide de ces écarts mais ça sera
le bazar qui va être répandu dans toutes
les entreprises
et ça sera le nivellement par le bas
c'est une société low cost c'est eux le
renard dans le poulailler et ça va
favoriser ceux qui aligne par le bas au
lieu de favoriser ceux qui élèvent que
françois est mauvaise françois hollande
a tort mais il a complètement tort sur
le fond et sur la forme dans votre livre
nicolas dupont aignan voit la france
lève toi et marche vous dit que il ya
une préférence française française paris
européenne pour le chômage dans notre
pays alors vous réclamer des réformes
d'envergure réforme du code du travail
en est une mais ce n'est pas une réforme
du code du travail la loi comme vous je
préconise une réforme fondamentale qui
est d'inciter à produire français car la
loi elle conneries comme les réformes
proposées par les républicains
c'est la gestion de l'alignement des
salariés français sur le salarié roumain
c'est ça en fait
et bientôt sur le salarié chinois c'est
à dire qu'au lieu de se dire comment on
va produire français
comment on va élever le niveau comment
va monter en gamme
comment on va faire des efforts de
productivité eux ils ont abandonné et
donc ils disent faux précariser les
salariés comme les autres eux c'est tous
les autres à droite qui possède à la
ligne de bruxelles cette loi elle est
imposée par bruxelles
e la réalité l'a imposée par bruxelles
ou par certaines réalités de notre pays
mais la réalité notre pays c'est
d'attirer de la richesse
si cette loi baisser les charges sur les
pme si cette loi et supprimait les
travailleurs détachés c'est à dire le
régime fiscal et social qui favorise
l'embauché de travailleurs roumains
polonais espagnols qui ne payent pas les
charges sociales françaises c'est à dire
si cette loi elle s'attaquait à la
concurrence déloyale
et qu'elle favorisait les pme françaises
mais je la voterai mais cette loi c'est
l'histoire elles vivent les travailleurs
détachés nicolas dupont aignan c'est là
la france et engagez vous le savez
contre le système des travailleurs des
nordiques et qui aboutit à du dumping
social c'est vrai on le voit la france
n'est pas engagée de dans la halle en
france soutient les efforts de la
condition pour durcir ce régime
ça c'est du pipeau c'est du cinéma en
attendant il ya cinq cent mille
travailleurs détachés en france coût
horaire 14 euros charges comprises il ya
des francs le coût est moins sûr même le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui il ya cinq
cent mille emplois volé ce sont des
voleurs d'emploi et eux avec la
complicité du gouvernement français qui
met la france dans la rue pour une loi
travail incompréhensible et au même
moment
il suffirait de dénoncer la directive
travailleurs détachés et d'obliger les
travailleurs détachés à payer les
charges sociales françaises du pays
d'accueil pour libérer cinq cent mille
emplois
mais reconnaissez quand même que c'est
ahurissant que le président de la
république aux resté une heure à europe
1 comme sur une à france 2 la semaine
dernière où il ya quinze jours et n'a
pas abordé une fois ce que tout les
patrons de pme artisans me 10 salariés
dans toute la france dire on ne peut
plus lutter contre la concurrence
déloyale des travailleurs en se
féliciter c'est un magnifiquement de
travail
ce dimanche on a vu partir le magnifique
paquebot le plus grand du monde
construit sur les chantiers navals stx
de saint nazaire et vous êtes le seul
j'ai l'impression à dénoncer justement
la présence de travailleurs détachés sur
ce chantier oui je le dis dans mon livre
j'explique oui j'ai été sur les bords
des quais on les avait des moldaves des
tchèques des roumains qui dorment dans
leur voiture et au même moment au pôle
emploi de saint nazaire il ya des
ouvriers qui n'ont pas de travail et on
donne du rsa sur fonds publics
j'ajoute même que je suis stupéfait
qu'on subventionne ces pays la france
perd 7 milliards ou 1 8 milliard par an
qu'il donne à l'union européenne
c'est-à-dire qu'on donne 8 milliards de
plus qu'on reçoit à l'union européenne 8
milliards cet argent va aider la pologne
très bien on les aide
pourquoi pas mais oui après c'est
heureux j'estime que maintenant la chute
du mur est passé depuis quinze ans il se
développe
je sais pays la pologne à sa monnaie
qu'il a dévalué et ensuite ces pays
subventionné par nos impôts vienne
envoient leurs travailleurs sur notre
sol nous voler nos emplois est ce qu'il
faut dire aujourd'hui nicolas dupont
aignan est censé séance pays européens
essentiellement des pays de l'europe de
l'est d'ailleurs qui disent non à la
révision de cette directive travailleurs
détachés l'europe
la belle robe que j'ai ce qu'il faut
dire la belle europe c'est pas la jungle
c'est pas la concurrence déloyale la
belle europe c'est pas l'alignement des
français sur le smic bulgare à 179 euros
la belle europe c'est l'élévation c'est
le rapprochement vers le haut et c'est
ça c'est bien son angle différent non
cela celle inverse bien son actif là
c'est l'inversé c'est qu'on aligne les
salaires français l'ol comrie programme
des républicains
c'est l'alignement des français sur le
moins disant social fiscal c'est pas
possible alors je le disais tout à
l'heure tous cas pas pour moi on a
compris et vous êtes là pour exprimer
vos idées que vous résumer donc dans ce
livre je le disais il ya cru surtout
qu'on peut faire autrement parce que eux
quand je propose par exemple de réduire
de moitié l'impôt sur les sociétés pour
les bénéfices réinvestis sur le sol
français
je donne un bonus fiscal ou pme qui
veulent produire en france
moi je ne suis pas pour dire que tout va
bien en france il faut aider les pme les
petits chefs d'entreprise ce qui le
mérite puisque tout va mal prévenant je
dis qu'aujourd'hui il ya une prime à la
délocalisation est au chômage et je veux
qu une prime à ceux qui apportent de
l'emploi en france
alors je le disais tout à l'heure dans
les manifestations vous l'avez vu
aujourd'hui à paris notamment à rennes
et nantes encore il y a eu des violences
manuel valls a répondu tout à l'heure
sur ce point on l'écouté vous réagissez
dans ce moment là
où on entend les mots j'ai même entendu
parler il ya encore un instant de
chienlit où s'expriment de la violence
et de la radicalité dans notre société
chacun je rappelais a sa part de
responsabilité et dans les mots qui ont
été parfois utilisé contre le texte de
loi porté par myriam el khomri dans l'it
rate à l'égard contre les forces de
l'ordre dans cette volonté de faire
reculer le gouvernement sur ce texte qui
nous paraît indispensable utile pour les
entreprises comme pour les sels pour les
salariés je veux appeler chacun à la
responsabilité
tout mot toute acte tout écrit qui remet
en cause même les principes de la
république y compris un article de la
constitution
l'action du gouvernement est aujourd'hui
un mot qui peut faire déraper le pays
alors voilà il ya les mots qu'on lit sur
les tracts sur certaines affiches et
puis il ya les faits françois hollande
ce matin a lancé un ça suffit à
l'adresse des casseurs la voulait donner
raison quelle tartufferie qu'elle savait
je pense à molière les tartuffes ces
gens qui mettent de l'huile sur le feu
qui laisse les casseurs faire et qui
après fonde l'amalgamme entre la colère
sociale légitime et les casseurs moi je
suis ils ont jeté de l'huile sur louis
quand on fait voter par le 49-3 une loi
qui est une loi de régression mais
profonde accord les 1/4 de 49,3 le
premier ministre l'a rappelé c'est une
loi constitutionnelle être mais il ya
des usages
vous savez quand on provoque les gens
quand eux on agresse à pop en gouvernant
contre ses intérêts quand on négocie un
accord avec la turquie en or par mira
violence et les gta non pas du tout mais
ce que je dis c'est qu'il ya une colère
sociale qu'il faut l'entendre et en
revanche j'aimerais que le gouvernement
soit plus ferme contre les casseurs
parce que le gouvernement est faible
avec les casseurs et dur avec les
salariés et ça c'est ce que j'appelle de
la manipulation n'a juste vous dites
vous dit le gouverneur vfl gouvernement
après démesuré ferrand est très faible
quelques mesures d'interdiction de
manifester enfin contre de certains oui
mais la justice administrative a annulé
ses intérêts et ses zones d'attraction
cole gouvernement qui est si prompt à
utiliser le 49-3 ne change pas un peu de
politique
al vous savez je crois que le premier
ministre joue la politique du pire
tant pis pour eux
il se fâche avec le peuple et c'est
dommage mais moi ça me fait de la peine
c'est d'avoir l'air ferme d'avoir les
referme alors qu'ils sont faibles
eux ils sont faibles avec les casseurs
faible avec les puissants et fort et dur
avec le peuple est ce que la police est
faible avec les casseurs selon la police
des critiqué par certains vous
l'entendez mollo les mecs et la police
défendre ce qu'elle peut mais nous
savons que c'est quand même ce
gouvernement qui a voté les lois les
plus laxistes en matière de sécurité
depuis quatre ans et donc c'est un peu
fort de café de venir maintenant dix ans
si vous êtes contre nous parce que c'est
sale
j'étais à l'assemblée cet après midi
j'ai entendu monsieur valls c'est
extraordinaire en gros si vous nous
critiquez
si vous avez des paroles politiquement
dur
vous êtes un casseur la manip elle est
grosse comme une maison
y a pas un français qui va y croire ce
qu'il faut c'est deux choses est
beaucoup plus ferme vis-à-vis des
casseurs les interpeller les arrêter si
on n'avait pas voté les lois pénales
taubira ça ira beaucoup plus vite
premier point rien n'empêche qu'on
vivait répète le ministre mais rien y
fait en paroles
rien n'interdit monsieur valls de nous
proposer une loi anti casseurs je
remarque c'est d'ailleurs la gauche qui
a annulé les loi anticasseurs
régulièrement donc que le gouvernement
propose une loi anti casseurs que le
gouvernement soit ferme contre la
chienlit n'est en revanche qu'on est
encore le droit en démocratie de
critiquer l'action du gouverneur que
vous irez manifester avec les policiers
demain oui qu'est ce que vous leur
proposez vous concrètement le problème
des policiers il est double il ya un
problème de moyens mais le gouvernement
davant avait été pire et c'est pourquoi
je l'avais combattu sur certains points
mais il ya un problème de respect est ce
que je demande est là c'est la mesure
principale c'est que toute agression
contre un policier donne lieu à de la
prison ferme
je suis maire d'une ville de banlieue
tout lancé peines planchers les grisons
faire de policiers et gendarmes
fondamentale deuxième deuxième point que
toutes les insultes crachats insultes
prise à partie donne lieu à inscription
sur le casier judiciaire et non pas
simplement rappel à la loi
je demande parallèlement qu'ils prêtent
des ambitions de légitime défense
notamment dans la police en faveur des
pronostics
dans les cas les plus graves
c'est-à-dire hold up à main armée actes
terroristes c'est à dire de permettre
aux policiers de réagir alors
qu'aujourd'hui ils sont complètement
bloqués il ya des aménagements comptait
annoncer la première aménage inistre
citoyens qu'avait l'intérieur
aménagements mais qui est insuffisant
voilà il y aurait une forme
d'irresponsabilité pénale pour les
policiers n'ont cessé l'idée que voulait
aller plus loin je veux aller sur un
point aujourd'hui
quant à policier est obligé de réagir et
qu'il y as doute il est dans une
procédure judiciaire qui va durer deux
ans où il est salie et il est lavé au
moment du procès je trouve que c'est
particulièrement injuste et tous les
policiers de france réclame une
présomption de légitime défense va vous
dire c'est un gars me tuer non c'est une
idée défendue par le front national
il part monsieur exemple via et par
d'autres corps et je vois pas au nom de
quoi je la défendrai pas mais je la
défends parce que les choses ont changé
par exemple la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme j'en ai rien à faire
voilà il ya un maître je n'ai qu'un m le
peuple français et s'il le fallait il
faudrait la faire adopter par référendum
il ya un autre mesure fondamentale c'est
la récidive et je propose qu au bout de
deux récidives à la troisième ailier
l'interdiction de prononcer un sursis
c'est à dire c'est le système américain
où vous êtes comptable de vos actes si
on ne fait pas ça et je pèse mes mots je
le vois dans ma banlieue
tous les jours les policiers ne sont
plus ni craint ni respectés françois
hollande répète que ça va mieux ce que
vous estimez que ça peut terminer dans
la rue avec des violences reste qu on y
est presque puisque c'est le danger que
vous soulignez dans votre livre nicolas
dupont aignan savez il ya une belle
phrase de marc aurèle un empereur romain
qui disait vous pouvez tondre le peuple
alors c'était votre gentil
m'enfin on était à l'époque de l'empiré
romain vous pouvez tondre le peuple mais
prenez garde à ne pas l'écorché j'ai
rendu visite à 25 départements français
petite ville abandonnée il ya une
désespérance dans notre pays qui est
fait qui s'explique tout simplement par
le mépris du peuple qu'on aux dirigeants
et françois hollande ce matin me faisait
penser à louis saez et je ne souhaite
pas sa fin c'est à dire mais ils n'ont
pas ou marie antoinette qu'on leur
apporte des brioches
je crois que ces gens vivent hors du
temps sont totalement prisonnier d'un
monde et une vive plus sur terre et moi
je veux rendre le pouvoir à la majorité
silencieuse parce que c'est elle qui est
le peuple alors il y à un ancien
ministres de bercy qui vous séduit ou
comme qui vous a séduit inferno
montebourg il a escaladé le mont beuvray
hier il a fait un petit pas vers 2017 en
les côtes vous réagissez vous propose de
bâtir dans les mois qui viennent un
grand projet alternatif pour le pays
alternatif 12 appareils politiques et or
leur censure et audacieux dans
l'invention de notre futur système
politique est devenue une grande machine
à trahir
il en est définitivement épuisée est-ce
que vous l'inciter à poursuivre
reprendre son combat courageux dit aussi
ans native je la cite à venir me
rejoindre et s'inscrira debout la france
il ya déjà entre 6 et 8% des français
qui disent dans les sondages qui nous
sous-estiment toujours nous rejoindre
vous savez moi je suis convaincu d'une
chose comme lui d'ailleurs c'est que ça
ne passera pas par les deux principaux
appareils qui aujourd'hui s'effondre son
temps ce sont des fans système le parti
socialiste qui finira j'ai toujours dit
que le parti socialiste finirait comme
le pas aux grecques à 30 % dont colis va
y arriver
et puis comme les républicains qui sont
en train de répéter ce qu'ils répètent
depuis 29 ans confirmé que j'aime en
france sincèrement que arnaud montebourg
de l'autre côté du de la barrière se
tient un discours assez proche du mien
donc j'invite à nous mêmes a rejoint
heureux de vous entendre dire du bien
d'un
un homme politique aujourd'hui beaucoup
de bien de beaucoup d'hommes politiques
attendent ému celui-ci en a beaucoup je
notamment des sans grades de ses députés
sont des oligarques des incompétents des
manipulateurs lâche traître médiocre
carriériste cynique le troupeau de cl
oui comme ils ont choqué qu'ils s'en
aillent tous n'ont pas tous parce que
justement j'explique dans mon livre que
vous avez des milliers de mères qui font
leur boulot sur le terrain que vous avez
des députés des sénateurs joli site
ces députés vous souvenez du passage je
les sites qui font un superbe boulot
mais est-ce qu'on va continuer à être le
seul pays au monde le sol la seule
démocratie au mon art si près des gens
qui nous ont ruiné la dette était multi
par trois le chômage par deux la misère
l'immigration des gens qui nous ont
ruiné et qui se croit au dessus du
suffrage stop ça suffit alors on va voir
ce que vous vous présenter maintenant
puisqu'on va évoquer votre programme
nicolas dupont aignan avec michaël
szames est ce bien public sénat
souhaitez-vous d'abord la fin de
l'europe puisque vous réclamez la
renégociation pour être précis avec le
rwanda continent sous les flots à feu
les cas la construction que vous voulez
être négocié alors les traiter en
d'ailleurs les soumettant par référendum
aux français et d'ailleurs vous propose
au total cinq référendums
on va en parler l'europe aujourd'hui en
crise notamment face aux réfugiés
l'accord avec la turquie est combattue 1
mais ce matin françois hollande lui a
apporté à nouveau son soutien
j'étais au conseil européen et j'ai
travaillé que madame merkel pour qui en
accord avec la turquie
donc je vais pas aujourd'hui me
désengager pourquoi il fallait un accord
avec la turquie la turquie c'est un pays
voisin de l'europe où il y a deux
millions cinq cent mille réfugiés qui
pour certains d'entre eux traverser au
péril de leur vie pour aller jusqu'en
grèce ce qui a créé l'afflux que l'on
sait nous n'étions pas les premiers
concernés
c'était l'allemagne l'autriche la suède
qu'il était davantage mais j'ai
considéré que ce n'aurait pas été loyal
à l'égard de madame merkel
ce n'aurait pas été européen que ne pas
avoir un accord avec la turquie cet
accord il est exigeant
les milliards dont vous parlez ne
peuvent être versées que si les
conditions sont respectées
et les visas ne pourront pas être
attribuée pour les turcs 6,72 critères
ne sont pas eux-mêmes respecté alors je
ne suis pas d'accord avec l'édition que
prend monsieur erdogan
mais il y à un accord qui a été passé
avec la turquie cet accord doit être
pleinement et grands qui laisse michel
dupont aignan bonsoir mickaël szames s
françois hollande assume l'accord est en
somme il dit ceux qui sont contre cet
accord ne sont pas européens vous situez
vous mais c'est tellement grotesque
pathétique je pensais à daladier quand
je voyais que tu fonces lors nous
d'accord c'est elle mais eux cette
espèce de munich migratoires ou l'europe
l'europe pour moi c'est quelque chose de
bien c'est une civilisation et la belle
europe comme vous avez l'europe se
couche devant un chef d'état qui lui
fait du chantage et menaces qui s'est
couché françois hollande gaydamak est
allé discuter avec françois hollande
contrairement à ce qu'il a dit était
absent absent au sens et 1,1 milliard et
peut être un déloyale vis-à-vis d'un
gala merkel vous l'avez entendu anna
mais il est le valais pour le coup de
madame merkel donc on connaît mais le
problème de fond c'est comment peut-on
accepter qu'un état voisin important qui
doit être un partenaire je n'ai jamais
été contre la turquie comme partenaire
j'ai toujours été hostile à son entrée
dans l'union européenne
mais comment peut-on accepter de
négocier avec quelqu'un qui vous menace
est ce que vous avez accepté dans votre
vie professionnelle de négocier avec un
pistolet sur la tempe
moi jamais on peut pas avoir confiance
dans la turquie pas dans la turquie
gouverné par monsieur erdogan et je pèse
mes mots qui a joué double jeu avec
l'état islamique
j'étais en polémique avec monsieur
moscovici sur une chaîne concurrente et
j'ai retrouvé l'article que j'ai pas pu
citer du guardian un article britannique
qui monte les liens de la famille de
monsieur erdogan avec l'état islamique
qui se sert du robinet des migrants pour
faire pression sur l'union européenne et
ce faisant a laissé des passeurs
exploiter la misère humaine eux et qui
de surcroît est en train de mettre un
place un régime antidémocratique
je croyais que les valeurs de l'europe
c'était la démocratie alors on cherche
des poux part
et moi à monsieur urban qui est quand
même élu démocratiquement
c'est un honneur monsieur ban mais c'est
un homme qui est élu démocratiquement
bien sûr il est élu démocratiquement et
il dit des choses très justes et en même
temps on négocie avec une sur erdogan
mais je me demande jusqu'où on va aller
de surcroît le pouvoir en droit est en
phase totalement avec les valeurs de la
belle europe qui évoque le cas elle est
vraiment quoi le pouvoir en droit n'est
pas en phase avec les valeurs de la
belle robe c'est un pouvoir démocratique
et je ne vois pas au nom de quoi je le
conteste et sauve l'honneur de l'europe
dans cette affaire en disant stop à une
folie migratoires qui met en marche des
millions de personnes vers le continent
européen
contrairement à l'intérêt de ces pauvres
migrants comme à l'intérêt des européens
ça fonctionne regard des 6 milliards que
l'on donnait la turquie ya moins de
migrants notamment qui viennent de
graisse dix fois moins dit on constate
qu'il y ait quelque chose c'est que
cette ce tarissement est la preuve
exact que monsieur erdogan pouvait très
bien s'attaquer aux passeurs sans avoir
besoin des 6 milliards il a suffi que
monsieur erdogan 10 je stoppe j'ai été
en turquie j'étais alejos tout le monde
savait que les pasteurs étaient protégés
par la police turque
donc ça veut dire qu'on accepte qu'un
état voisin un partenaire nous manipuler
manipule nos opinions et se sert de la
misère il est conscient et bien
évidemment puisque derrière vdab et la
libéralisation des visas qui est un
problème majeur libre circulation sur
schengen de 80 millions de turcs
et puis on nous avait pardonnez moi
comment sont donnés les passeport turc
au turcophone c'est un problème de
sécurité publique majeur et un problème
d'immigration majeur donc je vous le dis
très clairement nous avions d'autres
moyens pour contraindre erdogan à
respecter la démocratie et aussi à
contrôler les passeurs et vous dire que
le président de l'amm et est élu
démocratiquement en turquie non je ne la
pas mais je ne nie pas non plus que
monsieur erdogan s'accommode de la
démocratie de manière assez curieuse et
je remarquerai aussi que ça ne choque
personne que monsieur erdogan massacre
les kurdes qui sont quand même nos
alliés face à l'état islam et gens qui
je vous le rappelle a tué 130
personne sur les trottoirs de paris et
je suis indignée de cette faillite
morale du pouvoir français et allemands
comme je suis certain que cet accord ne
va pas régler le problème migratoire car
vous savez qu'il ya aussi la règle du un
pour un c'est à dire que pour tout
migrant qui repartirait de grèce vers
l'ailleurs qui on en accueille à il
vient ne trompe on parlait français sur
cet accord scellé il ya derrière cet
accord scélérat que vous dénoncez un pas
peut-être supplémentaire vers le
processus dans le processus d'union de
de la turquie oui alors pierre moscovici
que vous avez cité le commissaire
européen qui était à votre place il ya
quinze jours
or on doit être par rapport à la turquie
à la fois dans une attitude de
coopération nécessaire mais aussi dans
une attitude de fermeté sur les
principes
c'est un pays qui est démocratique avec
lequel il faut coopérer notamment sur
cette crise de réfugiés mais pas
seulement qu elle aussi un important
partenaire économique à terme à 15 ans à
20 ans la porte peut être ouverte si
nous sommes capables justement de
dessiner un arc de valeurs de principes
et d'intérêt commun
donc ça veut dire que dans 15 à 20 ans
la turquie sera dans une europe mais
c'est le projet de monsieur moscovici
c'est le projet des socialistes sans
devenir mais bien évidemment ça avance
pas à pas d'ailleurs je lisais nicolas
sarkozy dans le monde ce soir et je
lisais qu'ils étaient opposés je m'en
réjouis qu'il ait évolué parce qu'il a
ouverte 12 chapitres de négociation donc
moi je suis candidat à l'élection
présidentielle parce que j'en ai assez
de ces menteurs successifs ils veulent
faire entrer la turquie dans l'union
européenne
c'est à danger majeur je serai le
candidat à la présidentielle qui fera
tout pour qu'on ne fasse pas cette
politique catastrophique alors que vu
que vous lisez les journaux vous avez
peut-être vu temps en temps la croix ce
matin l'interview qu'accorde le pape
françois à ce quotidien
le pape qui dit de la france qu'elle
exagère la laïcité ressemble en fait
trop bah écoutez le je respecte le pape
comme autorité religieuse mais je crois
que c'est l'honneur de la france est un
pays laïc et que c'est la condition pour
permettre aux français de vivre ensemble
quels que soient leurs religions
d'origine ou leur religion présente je
veux un petit peu plus loin il dit
une femme musulmane veut porter le voile
elle a totalement le droit de le faire
comme un catholique peut porter la croix
ça dépend où voilà et des lois pour ça
exactement et c'est pourquoi je propose
avec mon mouvement nous allons faire une
proposition de loi bientôt nous sommes
en train de la peaufiner qui sera quoi
qui sera l'interdiction du voile à
l'université à l'hôpital à l'école c'est
déjà fait et dans les services publics
et que les chefs d'entreprise et le
droit par un règlement intérieur de
l'internet est ce que vous faites c'est
tu proposes tu deviens tôt elle va
bientôt sortir
je vous en donnerai la primeur dans le
pape est très explicite il dit juste sur
un point le modèle français
ce modèle républicain auquel je crois
c'est le seul modèle qui peut permettre
à des gens différents qui gardent leur
identité il s'agit pas de le renier leur
identité de vivre ensemble dans la paix
et le respect et donc les routes pape eu
de régner sur les consciences mais nous
avons une séparation que je rappelle qui
vaut autant pour l'islam que pour le
pack ans que vous l'entendez ou que vous
le lisez dans la croix ce matin
justement dire que la france est en
quelque sorte victime de l'héritage des
lumières et de la révolution vient
écouter on n'a pas fait la révolution
pour rien on n'a pas fait la loi de 1905
pour rien c'est l'honneur de la france
c'est l'honneur de la france d'avoir un
espace neutre
c'est l'honneur de la france que ce ne
soit pas les autorités religieuses qui
gouverne
parce que c'est au peuple français de
gouverner et le peuple français il est
libre dans sa tête et la différence
aujourd'hui
vous savez elle est pas entre la droite
et la gauche la différence aujourd'hui
elle est entre ceux qui veulent rendre
le pouvoir au peuple français et ceux
qui veulent diriger sa conscience et
bien non le peuple français est libre
donc en déplaise aux uns et aux autres
camarades ou cette interview au journal
jusqu'au j'avais entreprises à la loi le
conneries à bruxelles le peuple français
est libre et il va se réveiller on va le
réveiller le peuple français vous allez
voir verra ça aux racines chrétiennes de
l'europe mais elles sont une évidence
pour autant ça ne veut pas dire qu'elles
ont le monopole de l'europe mais un
arbre a des racines
si vous êtes en désaccord avec le pape
parce que ce n'est pas du tout un livre
avocat mais non mais sur le sujet du
récent chrétienne on peut dire mais il
est un pilier
le festival 3 mai compris alors mais
j'ai le droit de tout le monde sait que
l'europe a des racines chrétiennes
est ce que ça veut dire un père malade
et non pas de le dire
c'est absurde est ce que ça veut dire
que l'europe et chrétienne à 100% non
bien évidemment et mais l'europe c'est
l'europe gréco latine l'europe c'est une
sédimentation d' influence
il ya eu une influence bien évidemment
aussi musulman il ya une influence de
plusieurs religions mais il ya cette
racine
comment peut-on imaginer qu'un arbre
prospère pouces si on lui coupe les
racines staps urd donc ce débat est un
débat comment dire absurde j'ai entendu
monsieur moscovici qui niait les racines
chrétiennes de l'europe
mais pourquoi eux d'ailleurs moi je vais
vous dire j'ai souvent dans les
signatures de livres des gens qui
viennent me voir il y en avait un qui
m'a dit je ne suis pas venu en france il
s'appelait karim
il était musulman il m'a dit je ne suis
pas venu en france pour retrouver ce que
j'ai quitté et il m'a dit je vous
félicite de défendre à une idée de la
france
kate unis des laïcs généreuse mais qui
tient bon sur ses valeurs alors vous
avez déjà beaucoup cité nicolas sarkozy
je le constate pour ce team interview
sur l'europe mais ça m'a impressionné
ça vous avez sillonné alors les
questions à candé collectionner et
notables il veut créer un euro schengen
c'est une sorte de grand ministère avec
tous les ministères de tous les
ministres de l'intérieur qui formeraient
donc un grand ministère de l'europe
sache aucune harmonisation celle que
vous êtes eut réclamé sachant que je 20
ans veut depuis le traité d'amsterdam
qu'on nous répète la même chose alors
j'ai lu justement ce que j'ai vu ça dans
la presse alors je me suis précipitée
lire l'interview et j'ai compris que
nicolas sarkozy ne serait pas le
prochain président de la république
pourquoi parce que faut vraiment prendre
les français pour des imbéciles qu'ils
ne sont pas pour une raison très simple
c'est que comment imaginez-vous qu'au
nombre de pays de schengen on puisse
mettre en place un gouvernement schengen
ce absurde ça voudrait dire que les
frontières sont gérés par des autorités
alors définitivement par l'anam merkel
et ses copains ça voudra dire que nous
n'avons plus la maîtrise définitif de
nos frontières
et ça veut bien dire qu'en fait nicolas
sarkozy n'a pas changé qu'il est est ce
son droit
profondément heureux pays
qu'il abandonne la nation qu'il ne veut
pas que les français contrôle enfin de
sortir et lui parce qu'il ya un problème
moi j'espère évidemment moi je suis
claire je suis candidat car je veux
rendre la france à nos concitoyens
je veux des frontières je veux que les
français soient maîtres de leur destin
ce qui n'interdit pas une politique
européenne et une politique africaine
quand vous voulez être surpris de voir
que pas un mot sur l'afrique e66 ne plus
voir le doublement démographique est un
mot sur l'aide à l'afrique
on peut être ferme sur nos frontières
nationales
oui si parallèlement aussi on met en
place un vrai plan marshall pour
développer l'afrique car l'enjeu c'est
de stabiliser les populations africaines
et de leur donner une idée à la chose
qui a dû vous plaire dans cette
interview c'est important c'est sur le
référendum européen vous le souhaitez
bono le maire également mais en somme
nicolas même résultat nicolas sarkozy
vous dit le référendum
ce n'est pas la meilleure façon de
répondre à une question si complexe est
gentil mot vous dit en gros vous avez
tout faux il me fait penser à ces
avocats du suffrage censitaire et à ce
beau texte de victor hugo qui expliquait
justement que le peuple était tout à
fait capable de voter je le fais il a
violé la population avec une réponse
binaire
bien sûr et lui il a une réponse
complexe devrait faire interdire en
revanche la réponse a été très binaire
quand il s'est agi de s'asseoir sur le
vote des français de 2005 tous ceux qui
m'écoutent savent que les français ont
voté non en 2005 et celui qui a trahi la
parole du peuple c'est nicolas sarkozy
avec le soutien des socialistes
alors on oui ou non ce sont les
britanniques et qui vont voter ils ont
de la chance ils ont le droit
alors bon il thompson a comparé l'union
européenne à hitler ou à napoléon
vous allez pouvoir réagir alors que le
président du conseil européen atone
altus l'ua il s'est fâché mais enfin on
va le voir centre véritable excédant les
mots boris johnson a dépassé les limites
d'une discussion rationnelle faisant
preuve d'amnésie politique d'une
certaine façon il a illustré l'état
d'esprit et le sentiment de beaucoup
d'européens pas seulement au royaume-uni
où elle était d'être au loin faute
politique saad un bon style clair chacun
de vous a choqué sur ce qui est sûr
c'est que système bruxellois est une
forme de nouvelles occupations et que la
démocratie est en péril la démocratie
est en péril en europe moi je pense qu
une europe des nations démocratiques qui
récupèrent leur souveraineté sur les
points clés et des projets en commun et
c'est ce qui me différencie du front
national je crois à des projets
européens comme airbus voyons rêve
reprenant non ça c'est un cauchemar
c'est je crois on l'a vu je crois à des
projets concrets tels que les
l'imaginait le général de gaulle et
konrad adenauer
c'est à dire la lutte contre le cancer
par exemple pourquoi pas un beau projet
européen à trois ou quatre pays le plan
de développement de l'afrique
pourquoi pas un beau projet européen
l'union pour la méditerranée avec les
pays du maghreb et du nord de la
méditerranée c'est à dire france espagne
italie grèce
un beau projet quand on va sortir de ce
système binaire soit on accepte d'avaler
l'huile de foie de morue de bruxelles
c'est à dire un système de nivellement
par le bas et d'immigration massive
soit on est anti européen non on peut
vouloir une europe des nations d'accord
qui partagent des projets comme acquise
ont admis qu'elles rassurent vos
différences que vous revendiquez avec le
front national qui ont vendu sans
conteste mais comme lors de la bataille
de verdun
décidez de peu de jours le concert du
rappeur black m a été annulée est ce que
vous aurez joué c'est oui bien sûr parce
que fallait avoir une idée bien
saugrenue pour confier une sorte
d'hommage aux combattants à quelqu'un
qui a des paroles choquantes ont pas
aller plus loin et ce n'est la célébrité
et l'argent n'achète pas tout a répété
jeudi aurait mieux fait de chanter la
marseillaise
oui c'est sûr mais je vais vous dire si
black m était venu gratuitement chanté
la marseillaise et faire amende
honorable et dire je me suis trompé j'ai
dit des paroles que je regrette j'aime
la france
mais que ce soit black m ou x ou y je
m'en fiche
ce qui m'a choqué c'est que on croit
qu'on puisse acheter comme ça des
célébrités qui ont craché sur notre pays
ça suffit les français ont envie d'aimer
la france et moi j'aimerais qu'on parle
aussi on a parlé de beaucoup de choses
négatives parce que les événements sont
tristes mais il ya dans notre pays
de merveilleux acteurs des gens sur le
terrain qui font des choses incroyables
et ces gens là se sentent abandonnés et
bien moi je veux qu'on fasse réussir la
france et ça l'enjeu de demain et on
fera réussir la france il ya quantité de
chanteurs qui aimeraient chanter la
marseillaise à verdun et qui sont bien
mieux qu'ils le feront gratuitement
merci michael troisième partie de
preuves par 3 maintenant avec guillaume
daudin notre confrère d'une agence
france presse
nicolas dupont aignan souhaitez-vous une
alliance de tous les souverainistes
hostiles à l'euro par exemple jusqu'aux
extrêmes de l'échiquier politique j'ai
ça je vous vois venir et venir
et bien sûr ce point vous avez peut-être
être surpris écoutez d'abord ce que nous
disait ici même jean pierre chevènement
il ya quelques semaines prime
appellerait on rit comme tout le monde
intérêt à me rejoindre quand j'ai raison
1 mais vous aussi vous auriez intérêt à
montjoie et je m'adresse également aux
socialistes
je m'adresse également aux républicains
de l'autre rive comme je lé fais en 2002
je pense que les sonorités nos par
exemple pense que les solutions oui que
j'ai à vic n ya pas très longtemps dans
une réunion de république moderne aux
côtés d'arnaud montebourg
eh bien je pense que en effet la
solution c'est de le c'est une solution
de rassemblement jusqu'au tournant du
salut public jusqu'au front lat mais
l'électorat du front national
croyez moi il est mobile et il saura
venir là où est la terrifiante des
appareils et ceux qui désespèrent notre
pays c'est que les hommes politiques ne
s'exprime plus en fonction de son
intérêt fondamental c'est cela qui
explique la crise de la démocratie le
désarroi du pays et je pense que à
partir du moment on lui montrera un
chemin où il y aura à nouveau un projet
censé intelligent pour la france un
projet d'europe européenne qui ferait de
l'europe une entité stratégique à
l'échelle des problèmes du 21e siècle
heures qui sera dominé par la chine
février par les états unis et bien là
son homologue le peuple français
retrouvera confiant à vous avez bu ses
paroles à jean pierre chevènement
bonsoir monsieur danse la guillotine non
mais parce que jean pierre chevènement
que j'avais invité d'ailleurs les
universités d'été là en août dernier
résume exactement ce que je tente de
faire et ce que nous allons faire nous
allons réussir à faire parce que les
choses changent
je vois le nombre de soutiens qui
commence à venir pour ma candidature et
je peux vous assurer qu'il ya des gens
de gauche comme de droite et ya même des
gens du front national qui nous
rejoignent et qui avait été vers marine
le pen et qui en reviennent donc je
pense qu'on est tout à fait capable de
bâtir cette alternative politique
monsieur chevénement ne parle pas de la
personne pour l'incarner j'imagine que
vous pensez que c'est vous qui avez
cette possibilité à moi de le décider
moi je suis candidat je présente dans
mon livre un projet pour la france qui
est un projet patriotique et républicain
qui est un projet pour revoir
complètement le fonctionnement de
l'europe sans abandonner des
coopérations avec nos voisins
c'est un projet sérieux c'est un projet
e solide et le projet et il faut les
régimes politiques et la machine
polémique vite
arnaud montebourg à vous rejoindre
j'imagine que vous
vous aimeriez que jean pierre
chevènement vous rejoignent aussi et
puis henri guaino et puis beaucoup
d'autres je vais vous dire une chose
millions de da sur le terrain il ya des
mères qui était à gauche à droite
certains responsables front national qui
nous ont rejoints pourquoi ils le font
j'étais dans les vosges le responsable
du front national des vosges nous a
rejoints pourquoi at il quitté un parti
qui est à 30% des voix
j'ai pas été le chercher il m'a rejoint
disant voilà je retrouve chez vous ce
que j'avais eue rpr il venait du rpr
j'ai cru que ça existe front national et
puis c'est un tel bazar je préfère venir
soutenir quelqu'un qui a un vrai projet
est une équipe dont on n'a pas à rougir
des élus de terrain des responsables
associatifs des lanceurs dalet comme du
stéphanie gibeau eu des gens purs droit
cohérent et on va gagner à cause de ça
parce que eux
nous sommes des résistants nous sommes
des résistants et nous luttons c'est
vrai avec 1000 fois moins de moyens que
les autres mais nous allons gagner vous
pensez que le front national fait partie
de cette espèce d'arc souverainiste qui
s'opposent à la la construction ait eu
beaucoup de gens au sein du front
national écouter quels fonds national
monsieur guillaume daudin vous le
connaissez bien je comprends puisque
violin direction marine le pen que vous
connaissez aussi donc c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué que ça vous le savez
c'est le front national de jean marie le
pen c'est le front national de gollnisch
c'est le front national d'art nous tous
et le front national de filippo c'est le
front national e etc
vous le connaissez bien aussi comme
observateur je regarde le sacré bazar et
vous en prenez une partie mais voilà je
prends tout ce qui vole défendre un
patriotisme républicain qui redresse nos
entreprises et qui relocalisent un
million d'emplois qui rétablit la
sécurité en mettant les boyaux en prison
qui apprend à lire et à écrire à nos
enfants qui remet l'hôpital public sur
les rails qui renégocie tous les accords
européens et qui rend à la france le
contrôle de ses frontières
et qu'est-ce qu'il fait un programme de
salut public que je propose et je le
propose avec mon caractère mes soutiens
dans un esprit de rassemblement
gaulliste
qu'est ce qu'il faut le front national
soit acceptable et rentrer dans ce
chantier je n'ai pas à donner des
brevets il ya une élection
présidentielle nous ne sommes pas sous
la quatrième république
je me présente à l'élection
présidentielle je suis enfin heureux que
les sondages frémissent alors qu'ils me
sous-estimant plus à 6% et vous les
hanter 6 à 8 8% à 6% à 8 ya pas eu un
sondage en dessous de 5%
6 à 8% un an avant l'élection
alors qu'il ya 20 millions de français
qui s'abstiennent aux dernières
élections régionales alors longue ça
veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que les français attendent
une autre offre politique cet autre
offre politique je la bâtie je la
présente et on verra au soir du premier
ce que est ce que en voyant le front
national justement à 30% dans les eaux
jour d'hui aujourd'hui vous vous dites
pas que c'est plutôt lui qui incarne cet
autre flanc parce que vous savez dans
l'histoire ce n'est pas au poids moi
j'ai regardé les élections régionales et
j'ai constaté que les français aimaient
protesté avec le front national parce
qu'il n'y avait pas il n'avait pas
toujours connaissance d'une autre
alternative et j'ai remarqué aussi que
les français au 2e tour avait des
réticences à confier le pouvoir au front
national
pourquoi pourquoi il faut essayer de
comprendre et j'imagine que les leaders
du front national se pose la question
c'est pourquoi il se divise tant ce
moment là tout simplement
comme pour le parti communiste à une
époque parce que les français constitué
un vieux peuple sage il ne vole plus de
ceux qui nous gouvernent
mais ils ne lâcheront pas la proie pour
l'ombre ils changeront de cap
quand on aura défini très précisément où
on veut les emmener
et c'est pourquoi le jeu présente avec
mes amis de debout la france un cap très
précis un projet très sérieux qui va
leur permettre enfin et c'est ça la
nouveauté eux de ne plus être dans ce
piège monstrueux
soit on continue avec d incompétent
incapable soit on part à l'aventuré
et bien moi je refuse laventure
patriotique aléatoire et excessive et je
propose un chemin patriotique
républicain sérieux quand on réduit les
français choisiront quand on revient on
me reste un an pour les convaincre quand
on regarde votre programme
mais celui du front national on
distingue plus de similitudes que de
différences qu'est ce qui vous
différencie pour vous je vais vous dire
c'est la méthode douce et le programme
il ya deux choses
il ya une partie de programme je pense
par exemple sur l'europe où je crois pas
qu'on puisse envoyer balader toute
l'europe je pense qu'il faut des
coopérations qu'il faut se propose le
front national avec moins de précision
sur l'économie mon programme est
beaucoup plus en faveur de la libre
entreprise des pme est beaucoup moins
collectiviste je puis dire sur la
société notamment la peine de mort et
des choses comme ça mais je vais vous
dire est ce que c'est surtout là mais
c'est surtout la méthode je répondrais
c'est surtout la méthode vous savez il
ya trois parties en france aujourd'hui
qui veulent tourner la page note 3 à peu
près mélenchon est honnête il propose de
tourner la page avec le front de gauche
marine le pen elle propose de tourner la
page et petits nouveaux
debout la france aux régionales
pardonnez moi vous souriez
non je ne serai pas mais parce qu'il ya
ce vieux ni parler des trois larrons les
trois gros adversaire et comment vous
vous découvrirez je crois aux régionales
debout la france comme ça sans un
journal télévisé pour les régionales a
fait autant de voix que les verts ou que
le front de gauche eux dans 13
départements debout la france est devant
et le quatrième parti de france dans
deux mille communes chez au-dessus de
10%
donc on est récent vous avez mais on
progresse voix aux régionales on
progresse mais vous d'un million voilà
c'est simple mais les verts et le front
de gauche on entend beaucoup parler
nous nous sommes des nouveaux ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'enfin les français à
la présidentielle vont avoir la
possibilité de voter contre le système
sans tomber dans les extrêmes harry moi
j'en suis content je leur offrir ce
choix vous appeler à l'union
tous les souverainistes on vous entend
et que la rue mais pas que les
souverainistes et les autres aussi bien
sûr non attendez excusez moi oui à que
les souverainistes que attention le
mouillé et piégeux à ce n'était pas mon
intention
non mais moi je vous réponds gaulliste
gaulliste de progrès c'est pas la même
chose sourit nice et récupérer la
souveraineté mais après on en fait quoi
alors vous appelez sûr
la l'union mais alors d'en face
guillaume effectivement pourra le
confirmer
monsieur philippe au fléau philippot et
ben ils appellent aussi à l'union de
voter on les côtes alors vous avez dû
répondre cette fois où on a le courage
d'aller au fond des problèmes parce que
tous ceux qui viennent vous voir en vous
disant on va tout changer demain sans
rien changer
c'est à dire en restant dans le temps
les dans les mains de l'union européenne
qui vous empêche de protéger vos
frontières qui vous empêche de faire du
patriotisme économique qui vous empêche
d'avoir la souveraineté monétaire sont
des menteurs ou alors ou alors il assume
comme juppé comme juppé fillon
on va y venir et il bouge eh bien nous
on veut pas l'euro on veut pas baisser
la monnaie on préfère baisser vos
salaires et vos retraites mais je sais
pas le modèle que moi je veux ici voilà
donc on a une influence philippot qui
dit il faut une alliance des patriotes
c'est la seule solution et il dit par
contre s'il n'y a pas d'alliance des
patriotes c'est pas la faute du fn mais
je cite deux petits groupes qui veulent
exister pour des raisons et gothique
écoutez c'est pas la hauteur de
l'histoire ce sont des petites
polémiques
florian philippot et embringué au front
national aurait pu être chez vous vous
pensez
aujourd'hui notre main ce qu'il aurait
pu faire dans sa vie il est maintenant
dans ce marigot il le gère comme il veut
c'est son problème
je considère qu'on est en démocratie je
considère que les français sont piégés
je voulais dit par soit on continue soit
on va au front national et c'est ce qui
plaît aux systèmes comme le parti
communiste à l'époque renforcer
considérablement le système existant
d'ailleurs 7e gaulliste parce que y
avait rien entre eux ça a été le génie
mitterrand de construire une alternative
moi je veux construire une alternative
pour tous les français qui aiment la
france qui ne volent pas les excès du
front national mais qui pense qu'on doit
se débarrasser de ce qui nous mène à la
ruine
c'est obligatoire qui est des points
communs avec le front national puisque
je dis des choses évidentes que dit
parfois le front national mais que dit
aussi jean pierre chevènement ou arnaud
montebourg
mon mérite c'est bête opiniâtre et de la
vue et de continuer mon chemin parce que
je suis certain que le bon sens viendra
et que vous verrez nous allons
bouleverser le jeu politique je le
bouleverserait à la présidentielle j'ai
un an pour convaincre
alors il ya un certain nombre de gens
qui ne se contentent ni du fmi
public 1 aussi qui se réunissent à
béziers à la fin du mois sous l'égide du
maire de cette ville robert ménard on
les appelle la droite hors les murs il
ya plusieurs noms vous avez été invité
je crois à vous rendre là bas vous y
serez je ne peux pas y aller je lirai
avec attention les comptes rendus
c'est une démarche intéressante comment
dire de réflexion mais moi je suis
candidat à la présidentielle ma
réflexion est bien avancé j'ai un projet
un livre
j'invite à lire nous sortirons un
programme par tranches si je puis dire
c'est à dire par thème pour que les
français soient au courant du cap e
et puis en annonce mille fleurs
s'épanouissent comme disait mao tsé
toung en annonçant assez tôt votre
candidature à la présidentielle c'est
une manière un peu leur couper l'herbe
sous le pied de kiné pour vous voyez le
mal partout
c'est pas du tout ça c'est que moi je
suis plus récents beaucoup de français
ne me connaissent pas ne connaissent pas
ceux qui m'accompagnent dont on parle
jamais parce que ce ne sont pas des
personnalités médiatiques mais ce sont
des gens sur le terrain
baboo drum effet médiatique en dire un
mot je trouve qu'il enferme trop dans
des combats symboliques qui désespère
les gens et qui nourrissent l'abstention
est ce que je sais c'est que je veux
m'adresser aux abstentions que le
système médiatique j'ai envie dire
politico médiatique va vous faire
exister pendant encore un an puisqu'il
ya de nouvelles règles pour le verra
prise de parole on verra moi je vous
savez je fais je vais dans trois
départements par semaine je fais un
travail souterrain de terrain parce que
j'aime ça parce que j'écoute parce que
je suis pas là pour déverser un
programme clé en main je suis là pour
des échanges et je pense que si les
ministres faisait en ce moment où les
grands leaders entre guillemets grand de
droite faisais ce que je fais en ce
moment depuis des années je pense que
par exemple les travailleurs détachés
les frontières l'aide à la science eux
comment développe le la france paradis
des chercheurs bref tout ça il en
parlerait plus moi je crois qu'il n'est
plus vraiment en démocratie vous aviez
vous le dis franchement est la vraie
question allait démocratique comment
faire revivre la démocratie française et
je crois que c'est par la base et je
vous invite vous journalistes et je vous
remercie de m'inviter à faire en sorte
qu'il n'y ait pas comme dans certains
médias 90% de l'antenne pour
les deux parties qui nous ont mené à la
ruine qui ne représentent pas plus de
50% des jeunes vers ce que les gens ce
que laisse que les téléspectateurs ont
peut-être envie de savoir justement
c'est ce que vous feriez si vous étiez
président vous aviez dit en 2012 marine
le pen
arnaud montebourg jean pierre
chevènement premier ministre vous signez
vous signeriez toujours et bien sûr la
question c'est de savoir sur quel cap
et si c'était d'aller s'il serait
d'accord ce que je veux dire c'est quand
vous voyez henri guaino homme
remarquable
est ce que henri guaino peut cautionner
le programme délirant mais délirant que
vient de sortir sur le plan économique
alain juppé françois fillon bruno le
maire et nicolas sarkozy délirant résume
vous ne réduisez pas le niveau des
dépenses publiques
entendez bien évidemment qu'il faut non
d'abord je relancerai la croissance
économique est progressivement je
maîtriserai la dépense publique mais
dire comme eux qu'on va supprimer 100
milliards de dépenses comme ça c'est
soit mensongers soit casser
définitivement et créé un million de
chômeurs de plus c'est de la folie
mettre la retraite à 65 ans comme le
propose alain juppé fillon sarkozy et
les autres c'est créer des chômeurs de
plus parce que en attendant la tronche
mais je maintiens comme aujourd'hui
marine le pen fait de la démagogie dans
un sens avec mélenchon 60 ans et les
autres font de la démagogie dans l'autre
sens je veux relancer la croissance
économique par le produire français
voilà donc pendant votre campagne pour
reprendre l'expression que vous utilisez
un dans votre livre proposé trois
larrons vous allez combattre
françois hollande dit non vous en
faisait des mois
non non et vous demander si vous aviez
vous opposez aussi à marine le pen je
vais proposer un projet alternatif
positif pour mon pays car mon pays que
j'aime à tout pour s'en sortir on peut
réussir et la france est pas condamné à
décliner et à ressembler à la bulgarie
ou à la chine
vous attendez que la france se lève et
marche c'est le titre de votre livre
merci merci tout compris
merci à tous bon soirée la semaine
prochaine c'est christian eckert le
secrétaire d'état au budget qui sera
l'invité de preuves par 3 sur public
sénat avec l' agence france-presse
bonsoir à tous